Guillaume on vous en dit tout à l'heure
que nous sommes rendus à Marie pasula
bon je suis guyanaise donc je
connaissais la problématique des de mes
compatriotes mais ils ont pu découvrir
en tout cas dans quelles conditions les
passagers sont transportés entre Cayenne
et marie-pasoula donc c'est quand même
plus de 20000 personnes par an et ce
n'est pas un cas isolé selon
erguyan puisque nous avons rencontré le
directeur de la Guyane la Guyane serait
le seul département d'outre-mer où les
aéroports ne sont pas aux normes
européennes je sais que la gestion des
aérodromes incombe à la collectivité
territoriale mais elle peut pas tout
faire seul donc je voulais vous demander
qu'est-ce que vous comptez faire bien
entendu en partenariat avec la CTG pour
permettre au guyanais de voyager dans de
meilleures conditions parce que vous
devez savoir que les guyanais ont décidé
en tout cas de se prendre en charge
puisque il y a un collectif qui
travaille sur les routes de désenclavons
parce que quand on met la panne des
avions quelquefois qui dure 15 jours
donc nous compatriotes de de Maripasoula
ne peuvent pas venir se soigner à
Cayenne ne peuvent pas venir voir un
parent mal à Cayenne sinon prendre la
pirogue sur 48 heures en 48 heures donc
vous imaginez bien que c'est compliqué
je souhaite pas ici rappeler la
différence de traitement entre la Corse
et les départements d'outre-mer en
matière de continuité territoriale
d'autres le font régulièrement toutefois
j'ai beaucoup de mal à comprendre
comment l'État n'apporte que 1 million
cinq d'euros face aux 8 millions cinq
d'euros de la collectivité territoriale
de Guyane dans le cas de cette DSP d'un
montant de 10 millions d'euros
et si ma mémoire me fait pas défaut la
participation de l'État se limite à deux
lignes sur 4 c'est Cayenne marie-pasoula
alors qu'il existe Cayenne grand-senty
et Cayenne Saint-Laurent quels sont les
freins à une participation plus
importante de l'État et pour finir la
collectivité territoriale et la
compagnie Air Guyane rencontrent
régulièrement les associations des
usagers dans le but de travailler sur
l'amélioration du service rendu au
public la DGAC qui au nom de l'État est
signataire de la DSP ne siège jamais
dans ses réunions donc je vous rejoins
sur le défaut de service partielle ou
régulier en tout cas de la société
erguyenne qui est le même membre du
groupe Caire enfin la Hermione et
Antilles étant la même entreprise et la
même le même certificat transporterait
rien nous avons constaté comme vous des
défaillances dans le service promis
au titre de la DSP qu'elle a signé
elle encoura des pénalités pour ça les
pénalités sont rédigées les
procès-verbaux sont rédigés par les
régions Guyane nous sommes mains dans la
main avec la les services de la Région
pour leur les aider à rédiger
correctement ce qu'il faut comme
pénalité pas faire d'erreur juridique
parce que on est en face de nous des
acteurs qui sont malins aussi et donc on
est là dans ma main dans la main
éventuellement s'il faut pour pour
travailler à une
liaison supplémentaire par jour sur
marie-pasoula on y a travaillé avec le
président de la région
et donc ça c'est tout à fait vu
ce sont des appels d'offres si au
prochain appel d'offres il y a un autre
transporteur qui se présente je
conseille à la région de regarder ce
qu'elle préférable mais c'est vrai que
on peut faire mieux franchement sur la
participation financière de l'État
qui en effet de 1,5 millions d'euros par
an cette participation financière
est stable c'est-à-dire que elle était
la même avant lorsqu'il y avait le
système des aides au passagers et c'est
la raison pour laquelle sous le contrôle
les trois de nos collègues de ministère
des Finances nous avons maintenu cette
participation
au niveau où elle était dans le nouveau
système juridique de la DSP tout
simplement siéger aux réunions de cgio
réunion je peux effectivement en parler
au mes collègues de la Direction
Territoriale
anti Guyane parce que c'est une seule
direction territoriale pour nous à
l'aviation voir comment ils pourraient
se déplacer plus souvent être mieux
présent aux réunions comme vous l'avez
demandé